I play Daphne Milne I am the wife of a a
Milne and the mother of Christopher
Robin she is a very complicated woman
especially when you look at her through
modern eyes I didn't want to shy away
from any of her faults you know the one
good thing about the war is there lots
of marvelous women around like you we're
never going to get married because there
are no men so you can take on work
libraries yes that's true she could be
quite cold spirit and she had no time
for tears she had no time for
sentimentality all those worst things
she's never got anything just on the tip
of her tongue it's always just right out
there what Margot was doing has not
apologized for any of that she's just
said no this is who she is and this is
how she deals with things and she's
found the joy in that oh we're going on
holiday just to Italy for a month or so
they were the parents at their time but
it was quite natural to give birth and
head off to Italy for six weeks leaving
the baby with a nanny it's a different
time and it makes it so interesting to
watch this family dynamic ting just look
perfect
Daphne's definitely wanted to have a
girl I think that made it difficult for
her to connect with Christopher Robin
and yet you know you can see the joy in
Daphne's face when she gives the boy the
toy was clear she loved him very very
much in her own way very small yes quite
friends there'll be no trouble
do you have any objection to Tigers No
one of the reasons I wanted to do this
project was because my mom used to do
voices for my Winnie the Pooh and my
Teddy's which is what Daphne does to
Christopher Robin in this film Margot
and she is doing or the accents for the
toys I found it quite funny as alone it
was really nice you do know it was me
talking not the bad Elvises playing see
you see how instrumental she was to the
creation of Winnie the Pooh the whole
way through you see that she's the
driving force to creating this the
evening news was probably in the front
page without realizing it it was putting
a huge strain on her family
but she had the best of intentions he's
going to stay a little forever like my
boy
[Music]
you
you